णमो अरिहंताणं णमो सिद्धाणं
णमो आयरियाणं णमो उवज्झायाणं णमो लोए सव्व साहूणं
नमः समयसाराय
स्वानुभूत्या चकासते । चित्स्वभावाय भावाय
सर्वभावान्तरच्छिदे मंगलं भगवान वीरो,
मंगलं गौतमो गणी। मंगलं कुन्दकुन्दार्यो,
जैनधर्मोऽस्तु मंगलम्॥ सर्वमङ्गलमाङ्गल्यं
सर्वकल्याणकारकम। प्रधानं सर्वधर्माणां
जैनं जयति शासनम॥ ॐकारबिन्दुसंयुक्तं
नित्यं ध्यायन्ति योगिनः। कामदं मोक्षदं चैव
ॐकाराय नमो नमः
श्री द्रव्य दृष्टि प्रकाश।
पूज्य निहालचंद जी सौगानी जी के आध्यात्मिक पत्र। आचार्य को पत्र।
पत्र number है 17।
सनगढ़ के मुमुक्षु
को ये पत्र
आज से 48 साल पहले लिखा हुआ
है। पत्र की जो बात चली है, उनमें,
सनगढ़ से जो मुमुक्षु ने लिखा था उसका जवाब दिया है।
उन्होंने ऐसा लिखा था कि आपको बार-बार
बुलाते हैं लेकिन आप आते नहीं हो तो हमारे विकल्प बेकार जाता है।
कोई फायदा नहीं हुआ विचार करने से। बोले हमारा सिद्धांत ही ऐसा है,
जिन विचार का सिद्धांत ही ऐसा हो।
कि विकल्प के अनुसार कार्य होवे ऐसा कोई नियम जरूरी नहीं है।
तो कुछ गलत नहीं हुआ है। जो भी हुआ है नियम के अंदर ही हुआ है।
तो फिक्र नहीं करना क्यों विकल्प विकल्प ना हो कार्य... कार्य हो।
विकल्प मन में होते हैं और कार्य तो बाहर... होवे तो उसमें शरीर का भी योग होता है।
मन की गति fast है शरीर की गति... और वो भी जैसा picture बनाया वैसा बनेगा।
मन बोले ऐसा थोड़ा सा बोलता है।
इसीलिए... इसीलिए आपके विचार फैल गए तो आप दुखी मत हो जाओ।
कि हम बार-बार बुलाते हैं लेकिन आप तो आते नहीं हो। क्या? क्या बेकार का हजामत?
ऐसा मत समझो। दुखी दुख मत लगाओ।
दूसरा एक बात जो उन्होंने जवाब दिया था। वो उनके वो आरोग्य पर है।
आपको सतगुरु के चरण में नहीं रहकर के आपको
कुटुंबीय जनों के बीच में... करके आपको कुटुंबीय जनों के बीच में रहना बहुत ज़्यादा
पसंद है संसारी जनों के बीच में कैसे आत्मार्थी हो कैसे ज्ञानी हो
उन्होंने उसका जवाब दिया है कि जिसको मुक्ति चाहिए उसको
अपने परिवार वालों के बीच में रहना पसंद होवे और वहाँ सुख शांति मिले
ऐसी जो आपकी कल्पना है वो गलत है।
मुक्ति के मार्ग में चलने वाले को
घर संसार में थोड़ा भी सुख मिलता नहीं है। उसको तो अपने आत्मा में ही सुख मिलता है।
घर संसार के बीच में रहता है तो वो ऐसा संभव है।
जैसा पूर्व में कर्म किए हैं उस हिसाब से उसकी योग्य
जो film बननी थी वो बन रही है। ऐसे भाग्यशाली बहुत कम होते हैं। ऐसे
भाग्यशाली बहुत कम होते हैं
ज्ञान दशा के बाद निरंतर गुरु चरणों में रह पाए।
क्योंकि भूतकाल में जो कर्म किए वो तो
ज्ञान दशा के बाद भी भोगना तो है ही। ज्ञान दशा तो अभी
आई पर आत्मा के पुरुषार्थ।
लेकिन अभी चल रहा है कौन सा उदय चल रहा है?
भूतकाल में बंधे गए कर्मों का उदय चल रहा है।
और अभी जो film चल रही है वो किसकी चल रही है?
Film में दोनों part अस्ती रोती दोनों film होती है। अभी कौन सा part चल रहा है?
कि गुरु चरणों में रहना नहीं हो रहा है तो रोती film का part चल रहा है।
Thanks to पूर्व कर्म। और पूर्व कर्म को हम बदला नहीं सकते।
इसी प्रकार से अभी जो भी स्थिति है,
वो picture को पलटा नहीं सकते, सिर्फ देखना मात्र है, जानना मात्र है।
आत्मज्ञान होने पर भी ऐसे
गुरु चरणों में रहना नहीं मिलता है तो वो तो हमारे पूर्व के पाप का उदय है।
और संसारी जनों के बीच में, कुटुंबी जनों के बीच में रहना पड़ता है,
ये भी हमारे पूर्व के पाप कर्मों का उदय है, contract है।
इससे ये बात कहाँ से सिद्ध होती है? कि संसारी कुटुंबी जनों के बीच में रहते हुए भी
हम हमारी आत्मसाधना नहीं होती है
और हमको... होती है और हमको वहां मजा आती है संसार में।
साथ में रहते हैं इसका मतलब ये थोड़ा है कि हमको मजा आती है।
ऐसे तो कमल का पत्ता किसमें रहता है? कीचड़ में।
लेकिन है जरा भी लेप है उनके पत्तों को,
दाली को। कमल को छूता भी नहीं है कीचड़ को। ऐसे ज्ञानी कैसे रहते हैं?
जल में कमल रहता है ऐसे।
गुरु चरणों में रहे तो ज्ञानी है
और गुरु चरण...
गुरु चरणों में रहे तो ज्ञानी और गुरु चरणों में नहीं रह करके संसार में
संसारी के बीच में रहे तो अज्ञानी।
ऐसा कोई ज्ञान अज्ञान का कोई नियम नहीं है। बाहर की जो film है
उसमें तो पूर्व में किए गए जो कर्म बंधन है उसका जो उदय होता है उस अनुसार होता है।
आप बहुत lucky हो। मैं इतना भाग्यशाली नहीं हूँ इतनी बात। इसका मतलब ये नहीं
कि मैं भाग्यशाली नहीं हूँ तो मुझे... कि मैं भाग्यशाली नहीं हूँ तो मुझे
संसार में सुख मिलता है।
और मुझे वहाँ मज़ा आती है ऐसा नहीं है। ये बात उन्होंने यहाँ कही।
फिर अपने अंतर की बात बताते हैं कि ज्ञानी पुरुष अगर है तो उसको तो निरंतर क्या चाहिए?
आत्मरमणता ही चाहिए।
उनको तो किसी का भी संग नहीं चाहिए। अरे जिसको धार्मिक लोगों के संग पसंद नहीं,
उसको कुटुंबीय जनों का संग कहाँ से पसंद है? वो तो अपने... हुं तो
आपणे चैतन्यमां निवास करनार छुं. आ
केवी छे
जादुगरी? अमने समजातुं नथी. बहारमां गमतुं नथी,
अंदरमां
रहेवातुं नथी. ए जादुगरी अंतरस्थिति छे
ज्ञानी. ज्यां नहीं रहेना हे
वा रहेना पडता हे. ज्यां रहेना हे वा मुश्केल हे. भावना
तो हंमेशा... भावना तो
हमेशा ऐसी रहती है, अंतर्मेल है।
अरे विकल्पाचित पदार्थ से भी लाभ नहीं है। अगर विकल्प करें और वो पदार्थ मिल जावे,
तो विकल्पों के आधार से इतनी गुलामगिरी करके जो पदार्थ मिला है,
ना विकल्प से लाभ है, ना उन पदार्थ से लाभ। लाभ किधर से है?
लाभ तो अंदर से,
अपने आत्मा में लाभ है, और किधर लाभ नहीं। आपने
लिखा अभी तीसरा point का जवाब
कि revision कर रहे हैं दोपहर की चर्चा का।
कि निमित्त निमित्तिक संबंध ऐसा है।
कि आपका जो ये पाप का उदय है ना वर्तमान का।
जिसमें आपको गुरु चरण में रहना नहीं हो रहा। और जहां
गलत संग है, कुटुंबी जन के, संसार के संग में रहना होता है। जहां रहना नहीं चाहते हो।
ऐसा जो पाप का उदय है अगर आप भावना
तीव्र करो। पाप का उदय अगर आप भावना तीव्र करोगे तो पलट जाएगा। पाप
का उदय पलट करके किसका उदय हो जाएगा?
पुण्य भाव का। तो हमारी आपको ये सलाह है,
कि आप हथियार मत फेंक दो। क्या करो आप? तीव्र भावना पाओ
गुरु संग में रहने की। ऐसी भावना पाओगे तो क्या होगा?
कि जो पाप का उदय है ना वो
मिट जाएगा और पुण्य का... उदय है ना वो मिट जाएगा, पुण्य का उदय हो
जाएगा। पलट जाएगा वो परिणाम।
फिर आपको गुरु संग रहने को मिलेगा।
अभी आपकी भावना तीव्र नहीं है। तीव्र होती तो आप
कुछ भी सब आग लगा करके आते,
दुकान बंद करके भी भाग के आते। तीव्र नहीं है, खुला दिख रहा है। क्या?
तीव्र भावना करो, फिर पाप का उदय पलट के
पुण्य का उदय हो जाएगा। इसके जवाब में वो लिख। इसके जवाब में वो लिखते हैं।
देखो ज्ञानी का अंतःकरण उसमें मालूम पड़ता है। आज से जितना 48 साल पहले
data लिखा गया है। 64 में उनका स्वर्गवास हुआ।
इस काल की महान विभूति है, लोगों में प्रसिद्ध नहीं है क्यों?
कि प्रसिद्धि को चाहते नहीं। बाकी इनके जितना इनके जितना द्रवेद्र tree का जो
सामर्थ्य है ना।
लाखों ज्ञानियों में से एकाध कोई होता है, सभी को नहीं होता है।
इतनी जागृति। सभी को नहीं होता है इतनी जगह तक power शक्ति। ज्ञानियों
में भी ज्ञानी जैसे होते हैं ना महापुरुष
ऐसे होते हैं। क्या कहते हैं?
हमको तो ये बात सुन के अच्छी लगेगी चलो
गुरु चरण में रहने की भावना बाएंगे तीर्थ करेंगे तो।
कि पाप का उदय पलट जाएगा और पुण्य का उदय हो जाएगा तो फिर। फिर गुरु
के सामने रह कर के हम शांति से आत्मा की आराधना
कर पाएंगे। बात अच्छी लगती है लेकिन इनका ये
बात अच्छी नहीं लगती। अच्छी लगती है
लेकिन इनको ये बात अच्छी नहीं लगती। क्या कहते हैं? कि मैं विकल्प करूँ और
विकल्प के अनुसार मुझे पदार्थ
की प्राप्ति हो जाए, ये कोई पुण्य
थोड़ा है? ये तो पुण्य का फल है।
तो पुण्य का फल कब मिलता है? ये आम के ऊपर गुठली... फल लगते हैं, कब लगते हैं?
कि 3 साल पहले गुठली बोई है ना, तब फल निकलते हैं।
आज बोओ आज मिले ऐसा नहीं है। वो आज मिले ऐसा नहीं है।
ऐसे ये जो पुण्य है
गुरु के चरण में साथ में रहने का ये पुण्य कोई आजकल बनाया है ऐसा।
ये पुण्य नहीं है ये पुण्य का फल है अगर भूतकाल में बोया होगा तो जरूर मिलेगा।
तो गुरु का साथ मिलेगा।
लेकिन अगर बोया नहीं है और फिर आपको गुरु का संग मिले तो ये possible नहीं है।
तो विकल्प के अनुसार पदार्थ की प्राप्ति होना। ये
ये पुण्य नहीं है पुण्य का फल है।
और वो तो बोया होगा तो मिलेगा नहीं बोया होगा तो नहीं मिलेगा।
तो पुण्य किसको बोलते हैं? कि चाहे जैसे संयोग में भी हमारी तीव्रता ना हो जाए।
और समतर। Neutralize ज्यादा ना ज्यादा हर्ष ना ज्यादा शोक।
ना राग ना द्वेष ऐसा balance।
कि पाप के उदय में भी इतना दुखी दुखी नहीं।
के उदय में भी इतना दुखी दुखी नहीं होना।
और पुण्य के उदय में भी इतना हर्षित नहीं हो जाना। Balance में रहना।
पितृत्ता में रहना, उदासीनता में रहना। ये ये तीव्रता कषाय की मंद हो
जाती है। उसका नाम पुण्य
है। लेकिन उसका भी फल कब मिलेगा?
अभी ये practice करेंगे तो कब मिलेगा? भविष्य में।
वर्तमान में ऐसी practice अगर हम करेंगे तो उसका फल तो हमको भविष्य में मिलेगा।
फिर वर्तमान में क्या करना?
ये भावना बना कि नहीं बना गुरु चरणों में रहने की? नहीं इससे भी ऊंची एक चीज है।
क्या चीज है वो? कि राग छूट जाए।
या कम हो जाए। ऐसा होवे तो ही सुख है।
पदार्थ चाहे कैसे भी हो अनुकूल हो चाहे प्रतिकूल हो। और वो कैसे हो?
और वो कैसे होता है?
प्रतिकूल पदार्थ हो या अनुकूल पदार्थ हो हमको सुख सुख मिलता रहे। संभाव होता रहे।
कसाई दिगंबर हो ये कैसे हो सकता है? आत्मबल से होता है।
इसीलिए हमको शांति के लिए, किसी और के पुण्य की
या कोई पुण्य के उदय की या सद्गुरु की जरूरत नहीं है।
भावना अगर वाणी है तो आत्मा की बातें हैं। आत्मा के आश्रय से
राग की मान्यता हो जाए, करूँ नहीं करूँ मिट जाए, राग माने करना।
इसका opposite नहीं करूँ, वो द्वेष। आत्मा के आधार से
राग द्वेष करूँ नहीं करूँ ये सब मिट जाए और जानना देखना रह जाए,
मेरी तो ये भावना है।
मैं... मैं जानने देखने में रहने की कोशिश करता हूँ। मैं उड़े
में फेरफार करने की कोशिश नहीं करता हूँ, ना मैं चाहता हूँ।
मेरी ऐसी भावना नहीं
है। कि चलो जबरदस्ती भाग मारो थोड़ी करके दुकान बंद करके भले ही आग लग जाए,
भले ही भूखे मरना पड़े,
चलो गुरु के संग। ऐसा मैं नहीं करना चाहता। क्यों?
कि मेरा शांति का सागर है ना, वो गुरु के पास गिरवी नहीं रखा है। रखा
है। सोनगढ़ में डांट के नहीं रखा है। मेरा शांति का सागर कहाँ है?
मेरे पास। अगर समझो हमारे पुणे के उड़े से वहाँ पहुँच भी गया अगर गुरु के पास,
तो गुरु क्या बोलने वाले हैं? मेरे को देखो ऐसा बोलेंगे क्या?
क्या बोलेंगे वो? गुरु ये बोलेंगे कि भैया तुम इधर आए हो
लेकिन तेरे शांति का सागर तो तेरे में
है। इब मेरे यहाँ से... कि मेरे यहाँ से नज़र हटा ले और तुम कहाँ लगाओ
अपने में नज़र लगाओ 225 में है ये
point पिछले point के अंदर
सारी दुनिया को छोड़कर इधर आया। शांति पाने के लिए
पूरी दुनिया भटक लिए,
किधर नहीं मिला। फिर किधर आया? सद्गुरु के पास आया।
मैं क्या करूँ? उधर गया, उधर गया, व्रत किया, तप किया, मुनिपणा लिया।
क्या-क्या नहीं किया मैंने? बहुत कुछ किया, शास्त्र पढ़ डाले, पढ़ डाले।
और पढ़ कर ताला,
सब कर दिया ऐसा बहुत कुछ। यम नियम सब। बस साधन बारह। वो साधन बारो अनंत कियो।
तदपि कछु हाथ। अजुमर पोए। अब मैं फस गया हूँ।
जहाँ जहाँ हाथ पैर मारना था मैंने बहुत मारा लेकिन मुझे शांति
मिली नहीं। अब मैं आपके चरणों में आया हूँ।
अब मैं अपने बुद्धि से नहीं चलना चाहता हूँ। आप जैसा बोलोगे आप, आप अनुभवी हो।
आपको देख के ही लगता है कि आप बहुत शांति में हो,
आपको आत्मज्ञान हो गया है। मुझे ही मेरे परमात्मा... मुझे ही मेरे परमात्मा के
दर्शन करने की आस थी।
मैंने बहुत हाथ पैर मारे। अब आप जैसा बोलोगे वैसा करूँ मैं।
सारी दुनिया को छोड़कर के किधर आया? गुरु के पास। गुरु ने क्या किया?
अच्छा अब आया बेटा। पकड़ पैर मेरा,
उठ बैठ कर, जनबड़ प्रणाम कर, दक्षिणा कर, आरती उतार।
क्या? क्या? कांदा खिला और कोई किताब लिखता हो उसको चंदा दे किताब छपवाने का।
आश्रम बना सत्संग भवन मेरे लिए दान देना तुम सत्संग भवन बनाने का।
गुरु ऐसा बोलेंगे।
क्या बोलेंगे उनको? कि सारी दुनिया को छोड़ कर के जब गुरु चरणों में आया
तो इधर थपाट लगाकर कहते हैं कौन गुरु?
एक टमाटर ले आते हैं सब।
मूरख तुझे मालूम नहीं है कि शांति कहाँ है? शांति चाहिए मेरे पास क्यों आया?
मेरे पास है क्या? अगर शांति चाहिए तो भाई तेरी ओर जा।
किधर जा?
तो समझना वो सच्चे गुरु
हैं। कोई भी गुरु शांति के लिए ऐसा कहे कि... गुरु शांति के लिए
ऐसा कहे कि तू अपने आत्मा को देख तो सच्चा गुरु।
इतनी क्रिया कर इतना उठ बैठक कर इतने उपवास कर इतनी माला फेर। क्या
इतना चंदा दे दे। मेरे चरणों में पैर लगा आरती उतार वो गलत गुरु है।
करने और नहीं करने की बात आवे तो समझना कि गुरु नहीं है ये गुरु के भेष में
धोखेबाज है।
करने और नहीं करने की। करने और नहीं करने की बात करे कोई, इतना
करना और इतना नहीं करना। चौकड़ी लगा
देना सीधा। कोई अगर गुरु बोले शास्त्र पढ़ना compulsory है तो उसको बोलना आपको
नहीं मालूम। चौकड़ी लगा देना,
ज्यादा बुद्धि लगाने की जरूरत नहीं।
doctor के पास हम जाते हैं, भई हमारे गले में दर्द है। क्या?
हमारा इलाज कर दी।
doctor बोलता है देखो भैया, ये जो सामने book... ये जो सामने book पड़ी है
ना इतनी हज़ार पन्ने वाली, वो medical book पढ़ कर के मैं doctor बना हूँ।
इसमें गले का, हाथ का, पैर का, सबका इलाज लिखा हुआ है,
symptoms लिखे हुए हैं। मेरा भेजा मत खा। ये book उठा।
तेरा रोग क्या है तुम ही देख ले, check कर ले के पढ़ के दवा खुद ही कर ले।
ये क्या करेंगे हम वो
किताब उठाएंगे हज़ारों page वाली, अंदर में बारीक-बारीक letter होते हैं।
Medical book के letter गिन के होते हैं बहुत बारीक-बारीक। उसको क्या बोलेंगे?
book तो नहीं उठाएंगे। Doctor है कि हज़ाम
है? मैंने नहीं पढ़ा है, तूने पढ़ा है कि नहीं पढ़ा है?
तो मुझे बोलता है कि तूने पढ़ के।
तो ऐसे doctor तुम पढ़
लेके क्या किया? तो ऐसे doctor तू पढ़ लेके क्या किया तू तुझे मालूम नहीं है
क्या
उसको GPL करेगा नहीं चाहिए
ऐसा doctor नहीं चाहिए देखो क्योंकि तरीका गलत है अगर ऐसा ही कोई
गुरु शास्त्र पढ़ने
को बोले ना अपने को या माला फेरने को
बोले ना सही गुरु नहीं समझ
कुछ करने को बोला ना
गलत। करने को बोला ना खला।
पुरुष नहीं हो। जानने देखने में रहो। करना नहीं करना छोड़ो।
अवलोकन में रहो। क्रोध आए तो क्रोध का भी अवलोकन करो हटाना नहीं है क्रोध।
देखना है क्रोध।
भूतकाल के क्रोध को नहीं वर्तमान के क्रोध को उसी समय on the spot
सिर्फ देखना हटाना नहीं। ये इसका
key है। अगर ऐसी key कोई बताता। अगर ऐसी की कोई बताता है तो
वो ज्ञानी पुरुष है बाकी ज्ञानी पुरुष नहीं है।
करने नहीं करने की बात थोड़ा सा भूल जा। से यहाँ।
गुरु के चरणों में आता है कि मुझे शांति
चाहिए और मैं आपके चरणों में आया हूँ थपाट लगा देता है।
शांति के लिए तुम मेरे पास क्यों आए जा तेरे पास। जैसा आत्मा मेरे अंदर में है
वैसा ही आत्मा तेरे जैसा है।
तेरे आत्मा में मेरे
आत्मा में कोई फर्क नहीं। अरे भगवान के आत्मा में हो तेरे। अरे भगवान के
आत्मा में और तेरे आत्मा में कोई फर्क नहीं है, तू भगवान है।
तू मानते नहीं हो इसलिए भटकते हो। तू मानो कि मैं भगवान हूँ देखो अंदर।
अभी हो जाएगा कल्याण।
शांति अभी मिलेगी उसी वक्त मिलेगी। पुण्य का उदय तो अभी तुम खोएंगे तो
बाद में मिलेगा। और शांति...
गुरु को मिलना नहीं मिलना वो तो
पुण्य की अपेक्षा रखता है कि पुण्य
बंधा होगा या बांधोगे तो अभी नहीं मिलेगा। बांधोगे तो अभी नहीं मिलेगा कब मिलेगा?
उसका जब उदय आएगा।
और मुझे तो अभी शांति चाहिए। क्या करना कौन सी भावना पाना?
गुरु के चरणों में रहने की भावना पाना कि आत्मा में रहने की भावना पाना?
गुरु ने गुरु किससे प्रसन्न होंगे? नहीं मुझे तो आपका साथ चाहिए।
हमको नौकर चाकर की जरूरत नहीं। क्या
पैर दबाने वाले नहीं चाहिए कब न जाने कब गए गलत। न जाने कब गला दबा देवे तो। हमें कुछ
डर लगता है, दबाने वाले को डर लगता है।
न दबाने वाली हालत नहीं चाहिए हमें। गुरु को नहीं चाहिए ऐसे शिष्य।
कि मैं आपके चरणों में रहूं और आपकी पूजा करता रहूं।
कि हमको पुजारी नहीं चाहिए, हमको भगवान चाहिए।
हम बोलते हैं तुम भगवान हो, तुम अपने को पुजारी मानते हो,
तुम इतनी बात भी नहीं मानते हो।
जाओ, get out, नीचे उतर, तुम। जाओ get out नीचे उतर तुम यहाँ से।
नहीं आना तुम यहाँ से। भावना कौन सी भावना है?
वो सोमगढ़ से letter आया है क्या भावना भावो की गुरु चरणों में तीव्र भावना भावो।
बोलता मैं ऐसी भावना पाने वाला नहीं हूँ भिखारी नहीं हूँ। मैं तो आत्मा के आधार से।
चाहे जैसे संयोग में राग द्वेष ना होवे ऐसा आनंद मिले ऐसी भावना पाऊँ।
मैं अभी पुण्य की भावना में हूँ, फिर पुण्य का उदय आए तब गुरु मिले।
उदय आए तब तक मैं जिंदा रहूँगा कि गुरु जिंदा रहेगा? क्या?
तब तक गाड़ी छूट जाती है। मुझे अभी वर्तमान में शांति चाहिए।
वर्तमान में शांति चाहिए तो
गुरु के पास जाने की पुण्य की भिखारी भिखारीपना नहीं करना, गुरु का
या ऐसा पुण्य बांधने की ऐसी कोई भावना नहीं करनी।
तीव्र भावना नहीं करनी, जितनी तीव्र करोगे उतना उल्टे जाओगे।
शांति चाहिए तो एक ही भावना बना।
मुझे आत्मा को पाना है। फिर मैं Kolkata में भी जान सकता हूँ आत्मा को।
और सोनगढ़ आया हूँ, सोनगढ़ में आऊँगा तो भी गुरु मुझे
यही कहने वाले हैं, क्या कहने वाले हैं? कि
तुम बहुत गलती किए वहाँ से इतना आए।
चलो तुम अभी आ गए तो ठीक है लेकिन मेरे पास नहीं है तेरा।
सोनगढ़ में भी तुझे किसको देखना पड़ेगा?
शांति... शांति के लिए। कि मेरे को देखोगे तो शांति नहीं मिलेगी।
शिष्य अगर गुरु को देखे तो शांति नहीं मिलेगी। शिष्य
अगर परमात्मा को देखे तो शांति मिलेगी। और वो परमात्मा कौन है?
बैठा दे दे बोल। गुरु का यही कहना है। इसीलिए
मैं ऐसे पुण्य के चक्कर में आने वाला नहीं।
चखनी चखनी चुपड़ी चुपड़ी बातें हैं ना कुछ। चिकनी चुपड़ी चुपड़ी बातें
हैं ना फुसलाने वाली। मैं फसने वाला नहीं। गुरु के चरणों में बहुत आनंद है गुरु
दर्शन ती आनंद आनंद। आए सेरे।
किसी और को समझाना ये
बात। देखो बिल्कुल opposite है ये
बात। वो तो
जब हमारा उपयोग बाहर आवे।
हम अपने में नहीं रह पाए। और संसार में
जाने लगते हैं तो वहां से बचने। जाने लगते हैं तो वहाँ से बचने के लिए फिर गुरु
के चरणों में रहना। तब बोलना आपको गुरु चरणों में दर्शन से आनंद आनंद
आए छे, तब बोलना। पहले अपने परमात्मा के दर्शन करो।
फिर बाहर आओ तब। अशुभ से बचने के लिए गुरु की छत्रछाया में रहो
ताकि गुरु आपको
debrief करेंगे। क्या करेंगे? कहाँ से आए भैया? अभी परमात्मा... कहाँ से आया भैया?
अभी परमात्मा के दर्शन करके अभी निकला बाहर।
काहे को जा office। ऐसा करके गुरु धक्का देंगे।
ये जो धक्का देवे ना वो गुरु है। काहे को है भैया?
देखो। तो ऐसी जगह जाना।
और गुरु धक्का देते हैं ना इसीलिए गुरु के दर्शन से
आनंद आनंद होता है। अगर गुरु धक्का नहीं देवे
ना। तो मेरे पैर पकड़ो। और
मेरे पैर पकड़ो। तो कोई नहीं जाएगा
गुरु के पास। लेकिन गुरु पैर पकड़ने को नहीं
बोल पाए। गुरु परमात्मा को देखने को बोल पाए। इसीलिए गुरु दर्शन से आनंद
आनंद। Meaning है उसके अंदर।
वो अपुन दूसरा meaning करते हैं वो गलत है, ये meaning सही है।
आत्मा श्रीद राक की मंता हवे यही भावना है मेरी भावना तो ऐसे।
मैं दो। मैं धोखे में आने वाला नहीं हूँ।
शांति चाहिए direct जा सकता हूँ ना कलकानपुर में बैठे-बैठे।
शांति चाहिए तो मैं पहले जो
ticket वाले के पास जाऊँ line में खड़ा रहूँ reservation लूँ
train में बैठूँ दो
गाड़ी बदलूँ। 36 घंटे में मैं वहाँ भावनगर पहुँचूँ वहाँ से bus में बैठूँ।
फिर सीवर होकर के सोंघट में उतरूँ। फिर समिति कुशाल समिति में जाऊँ।
फिर गुरु के... फिर गुरु के गुरु कोई आ रहे
अभी नहीं आ रहा 3 से 4 lecture है तभी आना अभी बीच में ही ले लेगा किसी। गुरु
नहीं बोलेगा तो गुरु के चमचे
रहते हैं ना आजू-बाजू वो बोल देते हैं कि भैया disturb क्यों करते हो?
नहीं बहुत दूर से आया हूँ, आया तो क्या तुम्हारे घर से आया हूँ? कहते हो
चलते बनो यहाँ से। इतने लफड़े करो।
इसके बाद गुरु मुझे बोले कि भैया तू अंदर में जा तो
परमात्मा वहाँ नहीं था क्या Kolkata 36 घंटे के बाद 40 घंटे। 36 घंटे के बाद 40
घंटे के बाद इतनी मगजमारी करके
काहे को? मुझे ऐसी भावना निभाना है।
मुझे तो आत्मा के आश्रय से राग की मंगता हो जाए। वो भावना
निभाना है यही मेरी भावना है। अब आगे गुरुदेव का रेफिनर है। ये अपनी बात तो कह दी।
और जड़बा और जवाब दे रही
है। जिसके लिए लिखा होगा ना उसको तो
पसीना आ गया होगा। ये काहे को पत्थर मरा है देखा रखो।
पत्थर मार रहा है देखा रखो। और नहीं आ रहा है तो मत थाप काहे को
मेरे पर। इतनी बातें सुना दिया।
इनको संत तो नहीं होता है। बोला मेरी बात तो कौन माने? गुरुदेव का reference देता हूँ।
अब गुरुदेव का reference। इसको
तो बड़ा... कपड़े
में धोते हैं।
सिलाई करी। छोड़ेंगे नहीं? सिलाई नहीं छोड़ेंगे अब। सवाणी नहीं छोड़ेंगे अब।
कपड़ा रख के।
देखो गलत बताया
गलत decision लिया उन्होंने।
एक तो ज्ञानी को समझाने की कोशिश
की। और भावना भाव के संयोगों की भावना की बात करी देखो उमुख से की हालत देख लो।
गुरु का संयोग में रहना माने क्या?
गुरु के चरण में रहना माने क्या?
संयोग की भावना बना दी भिखारी बना दिया परमात्मा से। अपमान
कौन सा है? आत्मा में कौन सहन करे?
कोई ज्ञानी को कहे कि तुम भैया गुरु के चरणों में रहने की भावना रखो।
ये insult नहीं हुआ? Insult हो गया है।
कि मैं परमात्मा के शरण में रहता हूँ और
गुरु के order से जाता हूँ वहाँ पर परमात्मा के
क्या? और तुम मुझे बोलते हो गुरु के पास लेके आओ।
तुम बीच में कौन है भई दबदबा करने वाला? ये wrong direction
है बिल्कुल। इसलिए आप छोड़ेंगे
नहीं। इसलिए आप छोड़ेंगे नहीं उनको बहुत feel होता है।
सौगानी जी को बहुत hurt करके कहा है ये बात।
इसलिए छोड़ेंगे नहीं हम। अपना अपमान कोई सहन नहीं कर सकता।
और ये तो तीन लोक के नाथ का अपमान किया है।
भाई इसको छोड़ कर के तुम गुरु चरणों में रहने का भाव भाव।
काहे को भावूँ मैं ऐसा भिखारी को ना कहूँ।
परमात्मा खुद को छोड़ कर के भिखारी को
ना कहूँ भाव भाव क्यों भावूँ मैं।
नहीं चाहिए मुझे कोई केवल ज्ञान नहीं चाहिए। नहीं चाहिए मुझे कोई
केवल ज्ञान नहीं चाहिए जाओ।
भीख में तो मुझे केवल ज्ञान भी नहीं चाहिए। मुफ्त में तो कुछ नहीं चाहिए।
मेरे में नहीं है दम? अनंत शक्तियों का पिंड हूँ मेरे में दम है।
मैं अपने बलबूते पे केवल ज्ञान को लाना आना पड़ेगा मैं बोलूँगा नहीं आ करके।
केवल ज्ञान को मेरे पीछे पीछे भागते हुए दुम दबाते हुए आना पड़ेगा।
मैं नहीं बोलूँगा कि मुझे परमात्मा पद चाहिए मैं अभी परमात्मा हूँ।
मुझे सिद्ध भगवान बनने के लिए वो
शिखालय में जाने की ज़रूरत नहीं है, मैं यहाँ ही शिखालय में बैठा हूँ।
Power है उनका। और ऐसे महान पुरुषार्थियों को challenge कर दिया।
तो आप जूते खाएगा
बराकदास। अब देखो गुरुदेव क्या कहते हैं, चौगाणी जी बोलते हैं कि गुरुदेव कहते हैं।
कि इच्छा में
सावधानपन ज्ञान ही नहीं है। जो भी इच्छा विकल्प होते हैं
करूँ नहीं करूँ। उसमें जागृति ज्ञानी को कभी नहीं होती।
ज्ञानी को हमेशा जानने देखने के
जो प्रयास होता है ना उसमें जागृति होती है। तो ज्ञानी समझना।
करूँ नहीं करूँ तो बोझ लगता है वो। कोई भी ज्ञानी को करूँ नहीं करूँ बोझ लगता है।
फिर होता है कार्य।
लेकिन वो तो film बन गई है
वैसे होता है। तो film बन गई है वैसा होता है। करते नहीं हैं।
करने की कोई भावना नहीं है, विचार नहीं है। हमको लगता है
ऐसा करते हैं वैसा करते हैं खाते हैं पीते हैं, नहीं भैया ज्ञानी कुछ नहीं करते।
ज्ञानी सिर्फ जानने देखने वाले होते हैं। खाने वाले, पीने वाले,
बोलने वाले, चालने वाले,
डायरियां check करने वाले ज्ञानी नहीं होते हैं। दिखता ऐसा है।
ये बाहर का है, ये
ज्ञानी का रूप नहीं है ये। ये जो बाहर दिखता... ये जो बाहर दिख रहा है ना चर्मचक्षु
से वो ज्ञानी का रूप नहीं है।
ज्ञानी का रूप अंतर में है।
क्या करते हैं ज्ञानी? करूँ नहीं करूँ की भावना नहीं रखते हैं,
जानने देखने की भावना रखते हैं। जैसा उदय आया,
उसमें थोड़ा भी हेराफेरी मुझे नहीं करनी। सिर्फ जानने देखना मत।
ऐसा करो तो हाँ ठीक है, खत्म,
मगजमारी क्यों? एक भी... एक भी काम करना तो
बोजा लगता है. ए ज्ञानी के अंतर दशामां. क्या कहेते है?
गुरुदेव कहे छे. ईच्छामां सावधानपणुं ज्ञानीने नथी.
पोताना स्वभावनुं सावधानपणुं चूकीने, जाणमां देखवानो वेपार छोडीने,
एना भोगे,
पर पदार्थमां सावधानपणुं
ज्ञानी करतो नथी. लेकिन बाल में तो ऐसा दिखता है ना?
वो आपकी चर्म तंतु से दिखता है, ज्ञान तंतु से नहीं दिखता है। जरा गौर से देखो।
नहीं वो कवि प्रेम बोलता है। कहते हैं कि परमात्मा हमारे अंदर है।
क्या कहते हैं? कि परमात्मा हमारे भीतर है।
कवि प्रेम बोलता है, नहीं नहीं दोस्तों ध्यान से देखो। ध्यान से देखो
परमात्मा के अंदर हम हैं। कितना फर्क पड़ गया बात में?
हमारे अंदर परमात्मा उस बात में और हम परमात्मा के अंदर हैं उस बात में कितना फर्क है?
बहुत बड़ा फर्क है। बात तो होती है। ऐसे ज्ञानी का बाह्य रूप भी है।
मन वचन काय।
जो बाहर से चर्मोपक सुशरी दिखाई देता है। वो ज्ञानी का मूल रूप... वो ज्ञानी का
मूल रूप नहीं, अंतरंग रूप नहीं है वो। इससे ज्ञानी पहचाना नहीं जाएगा।
उसमें तो बहुत-बहुत
गतिविधियां हैं। घड़ी में jokes बोलेंगे, घड़ी में क्या-क्या करेंगे,
घड़ी में भजन गाएंगे, घड़ी में...
उनका अलग-अलग रूप रहते हैं। रसना कन्हैया की है ना, मटकी फोड़ते हैं।
गौवा चराने जाते हैं, बंसी बजाते हैं,
क्या-क्या नहीं करते हैं? मक्खन खा लेते हैं, च... नहीं करते हैं, पक्कन खा लेते
हैं, चढ़ा लेते हैं। वो बाहर की लीला है।
अंदर में क्या हो रहा है?
महान योगीश्वर हैं, जानने देखनो मेरे को। वो
वो जानने अंदर की बात कैसे देखने में आवे?
वो तो
चर्मचक्षु का विषय नहीं है,
वो ज्ञानचक्षु का विषय है। ये ज्ञानी की भक्ति करना,
महिमा करना, किसको देख कर के?
बाहर के रूप को देख कर के। बाढ़ के रूप को देख कर के बिल्कुल ये
जवाहरलाल नेहरू 18 घंटे काम करते थे।
सिर्फ 6 घंटा सोते थे देश के लिए 18 घंटा काम।
उनका एक सूत्र था मालूम है आराम हराम है। था कि नहीं था?
अच्छा। आराम हराम है। जवाहरलाल नेहरू। वो
कि 40 45 के लिए काम नहीं करते थे कितने के लिए काम करते थे?
भारत की 60 करोड़ जनता के लिए 18 घंटे रोज का काम करना। 18 घंटे रोज़ का
काम करना ऐसे बहुत मिल जाएंगे
भारत को आज़ाद कराने के लिए गांधी जी ने भी वो काम किया है
अपना तन मन धन सब कुछ अर्पण किया है अपना जीवन अर्पण कर दिया बिना
कपड़े के वो लोगों को देखा ना आदिवासियों को तो shirt पहनना छोड़
दिया ज़िंदगी भर shirt नहीं पहना बाद में कि मेरे देश में
मेरे बंधुआँ। मेरे बंधुओं। कपड़ा नहीं मिलता और मैं shirt
पहन के घूमूँ। ऐसे तो वो भी है बहुत है।
बाह्य वर्तन से आप compare नहीं करना।
बाह्य वर्तन से तो बहुत अच्छे-अच्छे लोग आए हैं। दुनिया Mother Teresa देख लो,
महात्मा गांधी देखो। बहुत इससे बढ़िया-बढ़िया मिल जाए।
ज्ञानी को देखना है तो अंतःकरण से देखो। अजोड छे अजोड.
ए वाक्य हतुं. के ईच्छामां सावधानपणुं ज्ञानीने नथी.
पोताना स्वभावनुं सावधानपणुं चूकीने
परपदार्थमां सावधानपणुं ज्ञानी करतो नथी. ए गुरुदेव कहे छे.
इसका भी खुद ही विस्तार करते है स्वामी. That means
ज्ञानीने ईच्छानी ईच्छा चारित्रमां... चारित्र्य
मोह और दर्शन मोह का संबंध बताया है।
ज्ञानी को इच्छा है खाने की, पीने की, ऐसा नहीं कि नहीं है, परमात्मा नहीं बन गया है।
घूमने फिरने की और समुद्र किनारे पे बैठने
की, नज़ारा देखने की। भक्ति गाने की।
आज कौन सा lecture है? तीसरा
है ना, दो दो होते थे, आज तीसरा है। ज़्यादा lecture करने की।
बहुत। बहुत बुद्धियाँ तो बहुत होती हैं, इच्छाएँ तो बहुत होती हैं।
ज्ञानी ने इच्छा से पर इच्छा नहीं, इच्छा... ये
क्या है? इच्छा की इच्छा का मतलब क्या
है? इसमें लाल बुद्धि नहीं है। मेरे आत्मा का कल्याण होगा ऐसा नहीं है, आग्रह नहीं
है। या मैं ऐसा कर सकता हूँ
ऐसी मान्यता नहीं है। जैसा होना होगा ऐसा होगा। जैसा होना होगा ऐसा होगा देखना
नहीं। भेद ज्ञान और जब ये क्रिया होती है उस वक्त भी उसी moment में
उसको भेद ज्ञान चलता है। ये जो भी हो रहा है सब अव्यवस्थित हो रहा है।
मैं तो सिर्फ जानने देखने वाला मात्र हूँ। ये
अंदर की line बाहर की line parallel चल गई।
हमको कौन सा subject देखना है?
ज्ञानी भक्ति करने योग्य है। कौन सा? कौन सा चीज़ देख कर के भक्ति करना है?
बाहर का नहीं। वेद ज्ञान वाला।
कि ये इतने सब करने पर भी कैसे हैं? अलिप्त हैं। ना लेना, ना देना।
ना राग, ना द्वेष। ना अच्छा, ना बुरा। अभिप्राय नहीं है, क्रिया है, अभिप्राय नहीं है।
इच्छाएं हैं, इच्छाओं की इच्छा नहीं। फिर क्या है?
क्या वो समझते हैं ज्ञानी अपने आप को? हैं ज्ञानी अपने आप। प्रदेश है प्रदेश है।
ये असंख्य प्रदेश है पूरे body
में, 500 प्रदेश। उसकी value, माप कितना, measurement?
इतना feet ऐसा measurement नहीं है। शास्त्रीय भाषा में measurement का माप क्या है?
प्रदेश। कितने प्रदेश हैं? 1, 2, लाख,
करोड़ ऐसा नहीं, असंख्य।
इस body जो है, चैतन्य body अंदर में है, जड़ body... चैतन्य body अंदर में
है जड़ body के पीछे अंदर में
एक क्षेत्रावगाह में चैतन्य body है ज्ञान पिंड ज्ञान की मूर्ति। उसके area कितना?
शरीर 5 feet का है 5 feet 3 inch समझ लो। लेकिन अंदर में जो चैतन्य विराजमान है
एक क्षेत्रावगाह में उसकी उसका measurement क्या है? वो feet में नहीं है।
उसका measurement प्रदेश में है और कितने प्रदेश हैं वो?
असंख्य प्रदेश हैं वो
one piece है। असंख्य प्रदेशों में one piece है। प्रदेशे प्रदेशे मैं।
मात्र। देखो शब्द देख लो। प्रदेशे प्रदेशे मैं।
ये मैं काहे द्वारा लगाया? ऐसा ही बोलता था प्रदेशे प्रदेशे।
केवल बात नहीं करना है अपनापन करना है। क्या? आत्मा ऐसा नहीं मैं आत्मा ऐसा बोलना है।
समझ में आया फर्क कितना है इसमें? आत्मा असंख्य प्रदेश। आत्मा असंख्य
प्रदेशी है ऐसा बोलो और मैं
असंख्य प्रदेशी हूँ कितना फर्क पड़ गया? ये यहाँ अपनापन आया ये
मेरी बात चल रही है।
सुनने वाला कैसा सुने? गुरु भले ही बोलते हैं लेकिन मेरा आत्मा ऐसा है।
कि प्रदेश से प्रदेश से मैं।
चैतन्य चैतन्य मात्र चैतन्य चैतन्य मात्र। इसके अलावा कुछ नहीं।
ये हाथ पैर खून dirt। हाथ पैर खून हड्डी हड्डियां फटिया ये कुछ नहीं है अंदर
किसमें
चैतन्य शरीर में क्या है मात्र
चैतन्य चैतन्य
और आनंद ही
आनंद से ओत प्रोत वस्तु में।
जानना जानना और आनंद आनंद शांति शांति शांति। जानना जानना और शांति शांति।
अपने को चाहिए क्या? चाहिए अपने को शांति। लेकिन leading में किसको रखा?
जानना जानना। क्योंकि ये माध्यम है।
हमको ज्ञान नहीं चाहिए ज्ञान तो है अंदर में लेकिन हमको ज्ञान नहीं चाहिए क्या चाहिए?
शांति। लेकिन फिर कैसे मिलेगा वो शांति? महसूस कैसे होगा? महसूस कैसे होगा
कि तुम ज्ञान को डोरी पकड़ के अंदर चले जाओ और जहाँ जहाँ ज्ञान है
वहाँ वहाँ आत्मा है और जहाँ जहाँ आत्मा है वहाँ वहाँ आनंद।
हमको मालूम है तुझे
क्या चाहिए तुझे आत्मा नहीं चाहिए। तुझे ज्ञान नहीं चाहिए तुझे क्या चाहिए?
शांति। लेकिन माध्यम क्या है? कि आत्मा पकड़ो
जो देह में बैठा है असंख्य प्रदेशी है। असंख्य प्रदेशी हैं।
तो असंख्य प्रदेशी आत्मा कैसा है? मात्र
चैतन्य चैतन्य मतलब सिर्फ जानना जानना जानना जानना जानना चैतन्य चैतन्य।
चैतन्य चैतन्य व अब उसका प्रयोजन की बात करता हूँ। ऐसे बहुत से गुण हैं।
लेकिन अभी जानने के बाद सीधा कहाँ पर आ गए?
ऐसे अनंत गुण हैं, चारित्र, वीर्य, बहुत से पुरुषार्थ। वीर्य बहुत है पुरुषार्थ। वो
उनकी बात नहीं करते main important बात कौन सी है?
शांति। शांति। तो चैतन्य चैतन्य। वो आनंद आनंद से ओतप्रोत।
वस्तु में।
असंख्य असंख्य प्रदेश मैंने क्या कर दिया area fix हो गए।
प्रदेश प्रदेश में मैं। Only मात्र। चैतन्य। मात्र
चैतन्य चैतन्य व आनंद आनंद से ओतप्रोत वस्तु
full लबालब भरा हुआ हो। जैसे सूर्य के अंदर प्रकाश भरा हुआ है।
सूर्य के कौन से area में प्रकाश नहीं है? इसी प्रकार से
ये अंदर में जो body में जो परमात्मा बैठा है, परमात्मा के every प्रदेश के ऊपर क्या
है? क्या है? चैतन्य चैतन्य। वो
आनंद आनंद से कोटि कोटि। ये वस्तु है। ये मैं हूँ।
इसलिए मैं शब्द पहले लगाया। किसमें अपनापन करो कि ये मैं हूँ।
गुरुदेव इसको बताते हैं। गुरुदेव ऐसा नहीं बोलते हैं कि तू किसको देख? गुरु को देख।
गुरुदेव किसको देखने को बोलते हैं?
इसको देख। ऐसा परमात्मा है। इच्छा में सावधान पड़ो
ज्ञानी ने। सावधानपणुं ज्ञानीने होतुं नथी. पोताना स्वभावनुं सावधानपणुं छोडीने,
पर पदार्थमां सावधानपणुं ज्ञानी करता,
शा माटे? ज्ञानीने ईच्छानी ईच्छा नथी. क्या मिल गया है?
के उनको बाळ में गुरु की भी जरूरत नहीं है क्या मिल गया है?
मोट चीज परमात्मा मिल गया है. मोड़ चीज़ परमात्मा मिल जाए कैसा है वो प्रदेशे प्रदेशे
में चैतन्य चैतन्य
और आनंद आनंद से ओतप्रोत वस्तु है।
अब नज़र चली गई यहाँ परमात्मा के ऊपर।
नज़र परमात्मा के ऊपर चली गई
अब स्वरूप की रचना करना है। अशांति को हटाना है। अशांति
को भगाना है शांति
को लाना है। ये स्वरूप रचना
अवस्था में पर्याय में स्वतः ही हुए जा रही है।
करना नहीं है। अशांति को भगाना नहीं है शांति को लाना नहीं है।
कहाँ चली गई नज़र? परमात्मा में। तो पर्याय अपने आप सुधर रही है automatic।
पर्याय में जो अशांति थी वो निकल गई।
और उसकी जगह स्वरूप में जो शांति
है वो... और उसकी जगह स्वरूप में जो शांति है वो बाहर आ गई। स्वरूप को
नहीं देखने के कारण अज्ञानता से जो अशांति,
दर्द, भय, चिंता ये सब थी,
वो निकल गई अपने आप। इसके जगह पे स्वरूप के अंदर जो पड़ी थी आनंद,
शांति वो अपने आप परिणति में आ गई। परिणति को सुधारने गए,
क्रोध, मान, माया लोक को भगाने गए, फिर क्या किया?
प्रदेश से प्रदेश से मैं मात्र चैतन्य चैतन्य
और आनंद आनंद से ओतप्रोत वस्तु हूँ, that's finish. ये बात finish हो गई यहाँ पर।
नज़र करते ही अब क्या हो रहा है, इसका result क्या आया? स्वरूप रचना
पर्याय में स्वतः ही हुए जा... होत ही हुए जा रही है।
जो आप चाहते थे आनंद वो अपने आप मिलता जा रहा है। अपने आप flow आता है energy से।
आप रोक नहीं पाओगे और सहन भी नहीं कर पाओगे। जबरदस्त flow आएगा अपने आप।
floor के ऊपर ध्यान नहीं देना। जो energy flow होएगी अपने आप।
पर्याय को देखने नहीं जाना कि कितना आनंद मिला। आप किसको देखना?
परमात्मा को। पर्याय में कितनी रचना हुई देखना नहीं।
हाँ वो नहीं देखना कि कितनी आनंद मिला।
वो तो अपने आप मिलेगा।
इसको पकड़ लिए ना तो व्यास
मुड़ी को पकड़ लिए तो व्यास तो अपने आप। आएगा। समुंदर है तो
बर्फी अपने आप आएगी लेकिन आप किसको देखना?
मूल पदार्थ को देखो। आनंद का समुंदर मैं हूँ।
चैतन्य का समुंदर मैं हूँ बस ये समुंदर को देखो। जब समुंदर
को देखा तो समुंदर। जब समुंदर को
देखा तो समुंदर भरती तो अपने आप।
ये automatic आनंद की भरती। आनंद की भरती को देखने नहीं जाना।
समुंदर नहीं देखेंगे। लहरों को देखोगे तो समुंदर को भूल जाओगे।
तुम लहरों को नहीं देखना तुम किसको देखना? समुंदर को ही देखना। परमात्मा को ही देखना।
आनंद की लहर तो अपने आप आएगी। देखो अब आगे। इच्छा तोड़ूं। इच्छा तोड़ूं।
राग भाव को तोड़ूं। अशांति को हटाओ।
ये करना नहीं करना हटा दो।
और स्वरूप की वृद्धि करूं, जानने देखने में ही रहूं।
करूं नहीं करूं भूल जाओ और जानने देखने में ही रहूं।
इच्छा तोड़ूं, स्वरूप की वृद्धि करूं आदि विकल्पों का, ये सारे विकल्प हैं। कि नहीं
वापस में राग द्वेष में चले जाओ। कि नहीं वापस मैं राग द्वेष में चला जाता
हूँ, नहीं जाना है। करने धरणे
में चला जाता हूँ, नहीं वो नहीं करना है।
मुझे जानने देखने में रहना है। ये जानने देखने में रहना है वो भी क्या है?
विकल्प है। आदि विकल्पों का जिस सहज स्वभाव में परमात्मा में
सहज ही अभाव है। ये विकल्प कौन कर रहा है?
केव करना धरणे से
नहीं, सिर्फ जानना देखना, ये विकल्प कौन कर रहा है? परमात्मा कर रहा
है। मन करता है। मेरे में नहीं है।
नहीं है। देखो कैसी ये system देखना।
निर्विकल्प अनुभूति करने के लिए जो उनके पास चाबी है ना
master की। वो सीखने का है इसमें सब गाणी। कैसी master की है देखो।
कोई गुरु गुरु कोई नहीं है अभी यहाँ। शांति चाहिए तो कौन है अभी कोई नहीं।
सिर्फ अपना परमात्मा हूँ। इच्छा तोड़ो,
स्वरूप की वृद्धि करो, आदि विकल्पों का, ऐसे बहुत से विकल्प, मैं परमात्मा हूँ,
मैं शरीर से भिन्न हूँ, यही मैं हूँ, ऐसे जो विकल्प, आदि विकल्पों का,
जिस सहज स्वभाव में सहज ही अभाव
है। अब अभाव है तो मैं काहे को दर-दर घूमूँ इसमें? अरे...
देखो और ऊंची बात करते हैं।
सहज शुद्ध पर्याय का भी जिस त्रिकाली ध्रुव वस्तु में सहज ही अभाव है।
ये जो आनंद की भर्ती आती है ना। ये शुद्ध पर्याय है।
करूँ नहीं करूँ वाली जो अवस्था है वो अशुद्ध है।
पाप पुण्य वाली जो अवस्था है वो अशुद्ध है।
और परमात्मा को देखने से जो आनंद की भर्ती आई।
कांति मिली उसको क्या बोलना। उसको क्या बोलना शुद्ध अवस्था।
परमात्मा में ये शुद्ध अवस्था भी नहीं है। क्या? अरे
मलिन द्वेष वाली पुण्य पाप वाली अवस्था तो मेरे में है ही नहीं।
लेकिन सहज automatic उत्पन्न होने वाली
आनंद की जो ये पर्याय है शुद्ध पर्याय है
उसका भी मैं त्रिकाली ध्रुव वस्तु में सहज ही अब हूँ। में सहज ही
अभाव है। आपके आत्मा में ही होती है ना?
होती है लेकिन वो क्षणभंगुर है और मैं कौन हूँ? त्रिकाली।
वो एक पल में आई और चली गई और मैं कैसा हूँ? मेरा उनका मेल कैसे बनेगा?
ये आनंद की लहर आई और चली गई, मिट गई।
समुद्र नहीं मिटा। लहर आई और वेदना आया और गया। लेकिन परमात्मा जिसके ध्यान...
लेकिन परमात्मा जिसके ध्यान से वेदन आया वो परमात्मा नहीं मिटा है।
किसकी value करना हो? वेदन के? मेरे को बहुत वेदन आया।
क्या काहे को खुश होते हो?
काहे को खुश बहुत आज तो बहुत रहा है। काहे को? तुमको आया? नहीं आया?
किसकी value है यहाँ पे?
अरे इस परमात्मा में ऐसे
अनंत वेदन है। यहाँ। अनंत वेदना है। होकर महात्मा क्यों होते हो खुश?
तेरी मंजिल तो है परमात्मा। देखना परमात्मा को।
नहीं वेदना आता है काहे को आदि को?
ये तेरे परमात्मा में थोड़ा वेदना है, तुम दूसरों को देख रहे हो।
वेदन को गौण कर। और नजर हमेशा परमात्मा के ऊपर
कर। अरे सरल सुख पर्याय का भी जिस तरह ध्रुव अर्थ में। जिस त्रिकालि
ध्रुव वस्तु में सहजी अभाव है
ऐसी नित्य वस्तु में अपना कम किया।
त्रिकालि परिपूर्ण भूतकाल में परिपूर्ण था वर्तमान में भी परिपूर्ण हूँ
और भविष्यकाल में भी मैं
परिपूर्ण हूँ। कमी एक percentage भी नहीं मेरे में कोई अशुद्धि नहीं
अंश मात्र भी नहीं ऐसी दृष्टि। ऐसी दृष्टि। ऐसी दृष्टि।
एक बार अवश्य अवश्य हो जाओ।
एक बार देख लो बस अपने परमात्मा को। कितनी बार? सिर्फ एक बार देख
लो। कब देखना
है? Hyderabad जाके। अब यहाँ तो पूरा 2 दिन ही है, क्या होगा? कब देखोगे?
ये hard लग रहा है क्या ऐसा? ये hard लगता है परमात्मा को देखना।
Easy है कि hard है? बोलता नहीं है कोई। अंधा बोलता है easy है। हाँ?
आप लोगों में तो किसी को करना नहीं है लगता
है। परमात्मा पे नज़र करना hard है कि easy है? Easy है।
किसके पास जाना है भीख मांगने के लिए? अब मेरे पास नहीं आना कोई direct।
कहीं दिखता है मैं सुनना नहीं चाहता। क्या करूँ कुछ समझ में
नहीं आता मैं। क्या करूँ कुछ समझ में नहीं आता मैं सुनना नहीं चाहता हूँ।
अब दो दिन मेरे को समुंदर के किनारे पे ध्यान करना है।
मैं सो जाता हूँ वहाँ। आपको बता दिया है
सौगानी जी अरे आप ध्यान आप
मैं मेरे पास नहीं है।
ये बोल दिया मैंने देखो क्या है।
के वहाँ जा करके नहीं करना है हरिद्वार में करना
है अपना परमात्मा यहाँ इसी वक्त है। और यहाँ कोई...
और यहाँ कोई disturb करने वाला नहीं, खाना बनाना नहीं है।
यहाँ थोड़ा बर्तन मांजने का थोड़ा problem है।
अभी वो तो कोई बात नहीं, 5 दिन में हो जाता है। मजा भी आती है थोड़ी practice हो
जाए। हम लोग भी कर सकते हैं।
बर्तन मानते मानते कितनी मजा आती है। बाकी कुछ करना नहीं।
कपड़े भी हम 2 दिन नहीं धोओगे चलेगा, वांधो क्यों है problem।
ऐसे ही मेली मेली रख दो bag में। बैग में। क्या?
स्त्री-विस्त्री कुछ करने की ज़रूरत नहीं है और जो भी है तो ऐसा है।
दो दिन ही है ना भगवान परसों कर तीन दिन के साथ में कर लेना। अब क्या काम है?
एक ही काम। क्या करना है?
परदेस से परदेस से मैं अपनापन करना। सिर्फ जानना नहीं अपनापन करना मैं।
वो मात्र... वो मात्र चैतन्य चैतन्य और आनंद आनंद की
ओतप्रोत वस्तु हो गई। That's all finish हो गई बात।
इतना ही कहना। तो
उधर नज़र कर लो। वो क्या
ऐसी दृष्टि कहूं ऐसी दृष्टि
एक बार अवश्य अवश्य हो जाए। बस
सुख समुद्र का दरिया वो जो दरिया है ना पानी का। का दरिया वो जो दरिया है ना
पानी का खारे पानी का वो नहीं। ये कैसा दरिया?
शोक समिद्र का दरिया। एकदम
सहज उमड़ पड़ेगा। शब्द देखना है कैसे जबरदस्त शब्द
है। Anticwriting. ऐसी दृष्टि परमात्मा की ऐसी दृष्टि
एक बार सिर्फ एक बार बाद में तुम नहीं देखना।
एक बार देख लेओ सिर्फ एक बार। एक बार देख लेना सिर्फ एक बार।
अच्छा। एक बार देखोगे तो भूलोगे नहीं कभी जिंदगी भर नहीं भूलोगे।
क्या? एक बार अवश्य अवश्य
हो जाओ ऐसी दृष्टि हो जाओ। Result क्या आएगा? बस
सुख समुद्र का दरिया एकदम
सहज बिना प्रयत्न automatic उमट पड़ेगा। Automatic उमड़ पड़ेगा।
पर के लिए विकल्प करना बेकार है, सद्गुरु के लिए विकल्प करना,
उनका सानिध्य मिले ऐसा विकल्प करना, साथ कभी ना छूटे ऐसा डर रखना
बेकार है।
ऐसा डर मत रखो, आपका परमात्मा गुरु के पास नहीं, आपका परमात्मा
आपके पास है। अरे, मैं बिना किसी के... मैं बिना किसी के ही
अभी ही परिपूर्ण हूँ। गुरु मेरे तो पूरा हूँ ऐसा नहीं हूँ मैं पहले से पूर्ण हूँ।
एक बार ऐसी तीव्र भावना होनी चाहिए। कैसी भावना बोला तीव्र भावना करो।
तो पाप का उदय पलट करके पुण्य के उदय आ जाएगा। सौगानी जी उसको क्या बोलते हैं?
कैसी भावना करना? मैं बिना किसी
के ही अभी। मैं बिना किसी के ही अभी ही परिपूर्ण हूँ।
एक बार ऐसी तीव्र भावना होनी। सामने जवाब दिया।
ताकि सामान्य वस्तु उसके
ज्ञान का अवसर आ जाए।
दृष्टि करोगे तो ज्ञान होगा। दृष्टि नहीं करोगे तो ज्ञान कैसे होगा?
एक बार नज़र कर लो। ऐसी तीव्र भावना से अंदर नज़र करो।
पर में सावधानीपना नहीं,
सो में सावधानीपना होना चाहिए। पुण्य के उदय, विकल्प,
सद्गुरुदेव, सोनगढ़। ठोकड़ी लगा दो सब।
मेरे सद्गुरुदेव और मेरा सोनगढ़ सब यहाँ है। प्रदेश प्रदेश। मेरे गुरु भी यहाँ
है। इसीलिए पर में सावधानीपना नहीं, सो में सावधानीपना होना चाहिए।
सो में सावधानीपणा होना time। यहाँ तक रखेंगे। अभी आगे
की wording तो बहुत है बहुत है। देखिए कहीं अनुभव करते करते दिखे हैं?